[Music]
there do I see my father my mother my
brothers and my sisters I see the line
of my people back to the beginning they
bid me to take my place some of them in
wolves on the Valhalla where the brave
Shaolin
[Music]
[Music]
so this is how most people victory a
Viking funeral some Viking most likely
related to the deceased persons of some
epic clothes and fiery the fire arrow
tower to both where the deceased is late
with all his belongings and the boat
burns down well just as with most of her
Memphis ancestry this view isn't quite
accurate but it also isn't completely
far from the truth before I start
talking about the Viking and or Norse
funerals I want to address the already
buttered people typing off in the
comments telling me that not all Norse
are Viking but all Viking or Norse this
is because the term Viking is mostly
used to just describe the northern
Raiders which were also pirates and
mostly farmers during the Viking Age
that pillaged Europe for about three
centuries as opposed to the word Norse
which is used to describe everyone else
from the European north that share a
common culture and language which
includes the Vikings but also includes
North traders settlers explorers and
just people living in northern Europe
not necessarily limited to the Viking
Age what do we know about Viking
funerals comes mostly from
archaeological finds Norse Sagas rune
stones and even some North poetry from
those we learned at Norse people during
the Viking Age preferred cremation over
a mount burial also called Timothy or
stone ship earlier both of which were
more common in pre Viking Age
Scandinavia however this doesn't mean
that those kinds of burials disappeared
completely a remains of Viking mounds or
stone ship burials around Scandinavia
somewhere used it straight up burials
sometimes including full-size ships some
are used for only Asheboro some we're
used for ancestral worshipping and some
are purely symbolic filled with deceased
Viking possessions rather than remains
which most likely were burned the two
main ways Vikings burn their deceased
was in a burning ship which we'll get to
in a moment and in a burning pyre the
pile was constructed out of wood in a
way as to form the largest possible
smoke stack this was because the Norse
people believed that the larger the
smoke stack the easier it was for the
deceased to enter afterlife the pie
usually contained along with the corpse
offering those we accordance with the
status of the deceased in the society
and sometimes also the person slaves and
even on occasion his wife the entire
procedure itself was very ceremonious
and this leads us to the burning ship
burial the only complete first-hand
account of a North ship burial comes
from a tenth century are a Muslim writer
named Ahmed his account goes as follows
when a great men dies the members of his
family say to his slave girls and young
slave boys which of you will die with
him one of them replies I will once they
have spoken it is irreversible and there
is no turning back
everyone busied himself about the dead
man and preparing everything that he
will need meanwhile the slave girl
spends each day drinking and singing
happily and joyfully when the day of the
funeral came they prepared the boat
fitting it with more woods and weapons
offerings including but not limited to
vegetables fruits food sacrifice dog
horses cow and chicken stew they
prepared a mattress to put the deceased
man on with a slave and everything was
overseen by an old witch
called the angel of death meanwhile the
slave girl who wanted to be killed came
and went entering and turned each of the
pavilions that had been built and the
master of each pavilion had intercourse
with her saying tell your master died
only did this for your love of him at a
time had come for the evening prayer
they led the slave girl toward something
which they had constructed and which
looked like a frame of a door
they then proceeded to look the girl
three times above the frame during which
she said there I see my father and my
mother there I see all my dead relatives
sitting there I see my master sitting in
paradise and paradise with green and
beautiful there are men with him and
young people and he is calling me take
me to him after the woman was taken on
board where she was made to drink by the
angel of death next six men entered and
lay with the girl one after another
after which they laid her beside her
master the Angel of Death came and put a
cord around her neck in such a way that
two ends one in opposite directions she
gave the institute of the men so they
could pool on them then she herself
approached a girl holding in her hand
the dagger with a broad blade and
plunged it again and again between the
girl's ribs while the two men strangled
her with the cord until she was dead
after which everyone left the boat and
the boat was set on fire by man holding
a torch who was completely naked after
the remnants of what was left from the
fire were drawn out of the river a small
mound was created on the side
with a wooden post inscribed with the
name of the chieftain and the king that
mentioned in Athens writing but usually
there was also a big celebration on the
seventh day of a man's death where
people would drink and the heirs could
only then rightfully claim their
inheritance so this is how a ship burial
looked like but this is also the only
first-hand account of a North ship
burial we have therefore keep in mind
this doesn't mean that all North ship
burials were like this in fact we're
pretty certain that areas all around
Scandinavia had different burial customs
with major overarching themes it is
important to look at the writer and
understand that even today to written
stories of the same thing may be widely
different depending on who is writing it
and same goes for this story NORs
burials are complicated and most likely
widely different depending on various
factors like the Status involve the
person or the area and era where it's
done or the actual people that are doing
the ceremony but that still doesn't
defeat from the amazement such customs
bring to our eyes today and they're
captivating your mental sized
counterparts of today's media
you